Mein Name ist Gejaj. Ich werde mit Ihnen das Erstgespräch führen.
Ich bin die Diensthabende Ärztin auf dieser Station.
Zunächst werde ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihren Personchendaten stellen.
Danach besprechen wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, das ist gut.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Maga Döpfer.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen langsam bestöpeln?
Ja, der Vornamen ist Maga, M-A-R-G-A.
Und der Familienname ist Döpfer, D-Ö, also O-P-S-G-A.
Ö-Umbau, ich konnte nicht ganz hören.
Döpfer, D-Ö-P-S-E-R.
Ö-Okay, okay, Frau Döpfer.
Genau.
Okay, toll.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Döpfer?
Noch bin ich 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt?
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. 3. 64.
64, okay.
Ich werde in einem Monat, 1,5 Monaten, werde ich eigentlich ein.
Ja, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,69.
1,69, wie viel wiegt sie zur Zeit?
Ja, bestimmt 70 Kilo.
70 Kilo, okay.
70, okay.
Wie heißt Ihr Haushalt oder Ihr Hausärztin?
Das ist Doktor Kübler.
Doktor Kübler.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Döpfer, ich kann Ihnen helfen.
Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Mir ist so furchtbar schlecht.
Ich habe solche grässlichen Bauchschmerzen.
Ich habe mich auch schon ein paar Mal übergeben.
Aber solche Bauchschmerzen kann ich mich überhaupt nicht erinnern,
dass ich so etwas überrage.
Okay, zum 1. Mal.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat eigentlich,
heute Nachmittag hat das eigentlich angefangen.
Und es geht mir so furchtbar schlecht.
Ich hatte so, ja,
ich hatte ein Mitbrötchen gegessen, zum Mittagessen.
Und mit 1 Mal ist mir so schlecht geworden.
Und ich habe dann auch Durchfall.
Also, das läuft nur so, das läuft nur so durch.
Ganz furchtbar.
Okay, Durchfall.
Hatten Sie Durchfallprobleme nach der Mittagessen?
Ja, nach der Mittagessen.
Was haben Sie gegessen?
Ich kann nichts verstehen.
Ja, ich habe so ein Brötchen mit frischem Mitt gegessen.
Somit Schweinehackfleisch.
Ah, okay, okay.
Ja, ich darf da gar nicht dran denken,
dass ich das gegessen habe.
Jetzt ist mir so schlecht geworden.
Das ist sehr unangenehm für Sie.
Ich verstehe.
Okay, und haben Sie diese Speisen alleine gegessen?
Ja, ich bin Taxifahrerin.
Da habe ich mir das schnell geholt in so einem Indies.
Ah, okay, okay.
Ja, und dann musste ich aufhören zu arbeiten.
Ich musste meine Schicht abbrechen.
Ich konnte nicht mehr weiterfahren.
Ich musste eilig nach Hause und auf die Toilette.
Und ich habe solche Bauchschmerzen.
Das tut so weh.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen aushalten
oder brauchen Sie eine Schmerzmittel?
Die Schmerzen ist nur so schlecht.
Vielleicht muss ich mich mal...
Wenn Sie mir eine Nierenschale geben,
falls ich mich noch mal übergeben muss,
das wäre ganz gut.
Ja, ich schmerze mich dann, oder?
Nein, wenn Sie mir nur eine Nierenschale geben,
falls ich mich noch mal übergeben muss.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie ein Brötchen?
Ja, ich habe mich mehrfach schon übergeben.
Mehrfach, okay.
Ja, aber da kommt jetzt gar nichts mehr.
Aber es wirkt halt immer noch.
Und ja, diese Bauchschmerzen sind so heftig.
Okay, okay.
Und haben Sie auch immer Überkeit?
Ich vermute, ja.
Ja, mir ist furchtbar schlecht, ja.
Furchtbar, okay, okay.
Und wie sah Ihre Erbruchene aus, Frau Düffer?
Gibt es Blutungen?
Das war ja ziemlich das Essen, was ich vorher gegessen habe.
Ja, okay.
Und wie viel Mal ungefähr haben Sie Überl...
Überl...
Erbruchene?
Nachher kam gar nicht mehr so drei, vier Mal, denke ich, ja.
Drei, vier Mal, okay.
Mhm.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen ganz genau beschreiben,
wo die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, also die sind so...
Eigentlich in der Mitte vom Bauch,
und das sind immer so Wellen.
Das kommt immer so...
Okay.
Ja, so Wellenförmig, ja.
Kommt diese Schmerzen attackenartig
oder meine See Wellenförmig,
das mit Attacken kommt und...
Ja, die sind immer wieder ganz schlimm los,
und da klaut es wieder so ein bisschen ab,
und dann hamfte ich wieder alles zusammen, ja.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen bewerten
auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10,
wobei 0 keine Schmerzen bedeutet,
und sehen die stärksten Schmerzen?
Ja.
Stärkste Schmerzen, ja.
Kopfab ist wahrscheinlich schlimmer, aber...
Also vielleicht so bei 7 oder so.
7 oder so, okay.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich hab gar nicht...
Ich hab versucht, ein bisschen Tee zu trinken, so Kamelentee,
aber der kam ja auch gleich wieder raus,
und der hat mir auch nicht geschmeckt, ja.
Okay, okay.
Strahlen Ihre Schmerzen irgendwohin aus, Frau Düpfer?
Nein, das ist alles so im Bauch, eigentlich, ja.
Okay, nur im Bauch.
Zum Beispiel rechtenarm oder unter Kiefer, keine, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, nur der Bauch tut mir weh.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Nun haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, weil ich mich so heiß gefühlt habe,
habe ich einmal gemitten.
Da, das war mit so einem Ohrthermometer,
habe ich das gemessen, das war über 38,
aber ein bisschen über 38, ein bisschen Fieber, ja.
Über 38, okay.
Und haben Sie, erhörte die Fieber seit heute Nachmittag auch?
Ja, das hat erst mal angefangen.
Ja, als ich mich so schlecht gefühlt habe,
da habe ich dann mich hingelegt
und habe einmal die Temperaturen mit.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit gelbe Suchtveränderung gemerkt?
Gelbe, was?
Gelbe Suchtverfärbung, oder?
Wer soll gelben verfärbt sein?
In Ihrer Körper oder in Ihrer Augen
haben Sie gelbliche Farbeveränderungen gemerkt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Ja, Frau Dürrfer, jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihren
allgemeinen medizinischen Zustand stellen.
Haben Sie nachts Schweißstallfrost?
Nein, nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Nicht okay.
Und haben Sie Durchfreigeprobleme?
Könnten Sie Ihre Stuhl beschreiben?
Welche Farbe ist das?
Ja, das ist so ganz flüssiges Zeug und halt so hellbraun.
Und ja, das ist also...
Das Schleim oder?
Ein bisschen Schleim, aber überwiegend eigentlich so wässrig.
Wässrig, okay.
Ja, und wässrig, gibt es keine Blutung, oder?
Also, habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen.
Nicht gesehen, okay, super.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit verändert, außer dieser Geschwärm?
Ja, außer heute nicht. Ich hatte immer guten Appetit, ja.
Aber ja, heute hat es mich also wirklich...
Nee, heute mag ich nichts mehr essen.
Okay, ja, das ist ganz normal, ja, jetzt.
Und wie ist Ihr Schlaf, Frau Deppfack?
Ja, also, wenn ich mal nicht gut schlafen kann,
dann nehme ich so ein Baldrian-Tropfen, das bringt mich dann so ein bisschen...
Baldrian.
Baldrian, okay.
Dann manchmal haben Sie Schlafprobleme.
Ja, wenn ich zu viel Sorgen habe, um so viel rumgrübeln oder so,
dann kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Okay.
Frau Deppfer, leiten Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzstäupen, Husten und Atemnurz?
Nein, nein, ich habe nur diese Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, Husten, ich huste natürlich immer so ein bisschen, ja.
Weil ich so ein Raucher-Husten habe, wissen Sie, jahrelang Taxi gefahren.
Okay.
Ja, da raucht man schon viel und zwar nicht mehr im Wagen,
aber eben in den Pausen.
Ja, da muss ich schon manchmal, habe ich so ein bisschen Husten, ja.
Okay, okay.
Aber keine Atemnurz, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nur Bauchschmerzen jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Okay, Frau Deppfer,
abrupo Nikotinkonsum,
könntest du mir bitte sagen, wie oft rauchen Sie?
Ja, also,
ich sage mal so,
ein Päckchen am Tag geht da schon, geht da schon durch, ja.
Ein Päckchen, oder?
Ja.
Jeder, dem wenn ich viel zu fahren habe,
dann auch mal ein bisschen weniger,
aber normalerweise, wenn wir viel Wartezeit haben,
dann brauchen wir ein bisschen mehr.
Okay, und seit wann brauchen Sie?
Oh, seit ich 20 bin, würde ich mal sagen.
Okay, ungefähr 40 Jahre, ja.
Das ist so viel, Frau Deppfer.
Sie wissen das schon, ich vermute, ja.
Ja, der Husten kommt ja nicht von ungefähr,
aber das ist jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht mein Lieb,
ich hab schon das Gefühl.
Okay, okay.
Wenn Sie nicht, wenn Sie nicht aushalten können,
kann ich ein Schmerzmieter geben.
Nein, nein, das geht schon noch, ja.
Okay, okay, Herr Herr.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Frau Deppfer?
Ach ja, ich trinke abends gerne mal eine Flasche Bier,
auch so ein bisschen zum Feierabend,
oder ich trinke auch gerne mal ein Glas Wein,
wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt oder so,
aber ja, so ein paar Mal in der Woche trinke ich schon abends
zum Feierabend ein Glas.
Okay, okay, ein paar Mal im Wochen.
Und nehmen Sie Drogen, Frau Deppfer?
Ja, Drogen, ich nicht, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, ja.
Ich vermute das, aber ich sollte diese Fragen hier in der Partie
nicht stellen, Frau Deppfer, ja.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unfallstöcklichkeiten?
Ja, ich darf tatsächlich kein Penicillin nehmen.
Okay.
Kann man mir mal gesagt, ja.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie, Penicillinallergie?
Ja, also eigentlich, die Hauptsache war nicht so ein heftiger
Ausschlag, ne?
Okay, heftiger Ausschlag.
Du kannst auch bejuckt und so.
Und dann haben wir aber die Ärzte gesagt, ich soll aufpassen,
das könnte auch schlimmer werden.
Genau, genau, das ist sehr wichtig, ja, Frau Deppfer.
Und haben Sie Unfallstöcklichkeiten?
Was meinen Sie, ja, wie gesagt, nur Penicillinvertrag?
Ja, nur Penicillinvertrag.
Okay, ich meine gegen Lebensmitteil, zum Beispiel
Milchprodukten oder Mail, weißen Mail.
Also, was ich mag, kann ich alles essen, ja.
Ja.
Ja, und Frau Deppfer, leiten Sie an eine kransche Erkrankung?
Ja, also wie gesagt, diese Husten, so ein bisschen raucher Husten,
und ja, ich habe manchmal so ein bisschen Magenbeschwerden,
aber also, dass ich mal so ein bisschen sauer aufstoßen muss
aber jetzt so wie heute, das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Okay, sauer aufstoßen.
Und in der Nacht, hat es ein Hochkommandes von Mageninhalt?
Ja, also selbstbar, aber manchmal passiert das ja,
oder je nachdem, auch, was ich gegessen habe, ne?
Manchmal, okay.
Trinken Sie viel Kaffee?
Ja, schon, ja.
Ja, zum Beispiel täglich, wie viel passen Sie?
Ja, wir stimmen jeden Tag zwei, drei Becher, ja.
Okay.
Wie ernähren Sie sich normalerweise, Frau Deppfer?
Ja, viel so Sachen, die man so schnell sich irgendwo am Inn missholen kann, ne?
Weil ich den ganzen Tag arbeiten muss, ne?
Genau, genau.
Und ich konnte nicht gut hören, in den ganzen Tag?
Weil ich so viel arbeiten muss.
Ja, und was Hause ging?
Bin ich halt nicht viel zu Hause,
deswegen muss ich mir immer so fertig Sachen kaufen.
Ah, okay, fertiges Essen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie manchmal Verstopfung oder Durchfallattacken?
Nein, nicht normal, ne?
Okay, normal, ne, nicht normal.
Mhm.
Ja, Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie
manche Magenprobleme haben
wobei Ihnen eine Magen- oder Darnspiegelung durchgeführt?
Ah, ist aber schon ganz lange her.
Mein Hausarzt hat mir damals gesagt,
dass man das so als Reizmagen bezeichnen kann.
Also insbesondere, wenn es ein bisschen Stress gibt
oder so, dass man dann so ein bisschen empfindlich reagiert.
Ah, okay, Reizdam sind Rom, oder?
Oder Reizmagen halt, ne?
Okay, alles klar.
Und Sie haben ab und zu Husten,
Sie leiden unter Husten,
wurde bei Ihnen eine Diagnose festgestellt?
Wie ECOSID?
Das ist nur, weil ich so viel geraucht habe.
Okay, keine Diagnose.
Und gibt es weitere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich war halt nicht immer ganz gesund.
Ja, muss sich auch immer irgendwie auf den Beinen bleiben.
Okay, wurde Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, so eine richtige Operation habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Noch nie, okay, super.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente ein,
außer bald Diagnose-Pfen?
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe,
dann nehme ich wohl mal so eine aspirin Tablette.
Okay, 500 Milligramm?
Ja, ja, genau.
Gibt es weitere Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe so ein Liebesgelrum.
Ja, okay, super.
Frau Dürrfer, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen,
wie Bluthoffdruck, Zuckerkrankheit,
oder Darmererkrankungen?
Meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs, die ist nicht alt geworden.
Und mein Vater hatte ganz früh ein Herzinfarkt,
so von chronischen Erkrankungen, sonst wüsste ich nichts.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwester?
Nee, ich war ein Zulkind.
Okay, und Sie sind Taxifahrerin, oder?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie viel Stress oder bei der Arbeit?
Ja, ja, Stress bei der Arbeit und auch mit meiner Tochter.
Ich habe eine erwachsene Tochter und sie ist halt drogenabhängig
und ist im Augenblick, sie wohnt natürlich nicht bei mir,
aber man macht sich ja doch seine Sorgen um die.
Ja, okay, das ist nicht einfach.
Und leben Sie allein?
Ja, ich bin geschieden und lebe alleine.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Frau Dürrfer?
Ja, das muss man ja sein.
Wenn man so viel mit Leuten kontakt hat, ja, ja,
also die ganzen Corona-Impfungen, das habe ich alles bekommen.
Okay, und alle Physikien haben Sie.
Ich habe mich schon gar auf die Grippe impfen lassen.
Okay, super.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Nee, da habe ich gar kein Geld dafür.
Okay, aha.
Noch eine Frage, Frau Dürrfer, wie, nein.
Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Sie sind im Wechselnjahr, oder?
Ich bin jetzt 60 Jahre, das ist bestimmt so 6 Jahre her.
6, 7 Jahre her.
Ungefähr vor 6 Jahren, oder?
Ja, also ich denke, 6, 7 Jahre ist das schon mehr.
Okay, okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen ärztinregermäßig?
Geht so, sage ich mal.
Vielleicht nicht jedes Jahr, aber so alle 2 oder 3 Jahre geht das schon hin.
Zum einen 3 Jahren.
Okay, normalerweise gibt es über 40,
viele Tests für Ihre Gesundheits-Tests.
Ja, aber da keine Zeit dafür, wissen Sie.
Ja, ich verstehe, aber das ist sehr wichtig für Sie, Frau Dürrfer.
Okay, ja.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Seit heute Morgen, heute Nachmittag, schuldigung,
hatten Sie sehr starke Bauchschmerzen.
Und wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben,
als Drücken, Stechens, Dumfens?
Stechens vielleicht nicht,
heftiger Druck und so ein krampfartiges Schmerz.
Okay, krampfartiges.
Wie vielmals hatten Sie bis jetzt diese Attacken?
Das geht die ganze Zeit immer wieder, ja.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, kommt und geht, aber sofort zurückkommen.
Okay, okay.
Sie haben im Mittagessen eine Schwein-Hackfleisch gegessen.
Und seitdem haben Sie diese Beschwerden.
Okay.
Und im Mittelpauch haben Sie diese Beschwerden
und werden für mich.
Ja, ja.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen bekommen.
Wie kommen Frau Düffa?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen an mich?
Ja, halt wie es jetzt weitergeht,
was mit mir los ist, ja.
Ja, das ist sehr früh um etwas zu sprechen, Frau Düffa.
Aber ich vermute, dass Essen abhängige Krankheiten sein.
Zuerst brauchen wir einige Untersuchungen und Befunde.
Um zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen,
danach Blut abnehmen und Stuhlprobe sollten Sie geben.
Genau, und danach werde ich eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen
und wenn wir alle Ergebnisse zusammengetragen haben.
Ja, das ist eine.
Entschuldigung, unsere Scheile.
Ja, unsere Scheile.
Und ja, werden wir miteinander noch einmal sprechen.
Ja, das ist doch gut.
Okay, gut, danke.
Bitte schön. Legen Sie sich ein bisschen.
Ich komme zur Untersuchung.
Ich glaube, die Anämnese ist strukturiert und vollständig.
Aber hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ja, bitte.
Wie häufig gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Oh, was habe ich gesagt? 5, 6-mal, 7-mal, 6-mal, 7-mal, ja.
Und wo genau, verspürn Sie die Schmerzen?
Im Bauch, so um den Bauchnabel rum und auch ein bisschen im Unterbauch.
Strand, Schmerzen, ihr geltet wo hinaus?
Nein, das habt ihr auch gefragt.
Danke.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgelommen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja, natürlich. Haben Sie den gesehen?
Okay. Es handelt sich um Frau Maga Düpfer, eine 60-jährige Patientin.
Sie stellte sich heute wegen, seit heute Nachmittag bestehender,
mit der Kampfartiger Abdominalschmerzen bei uns vor.
Sie beschrieb seine Schmerzen im mittigen Bauch,
die Umgebung der Narben.
Und diese Beschwerden bestehen,
die für mich aufgeladen werden.
Sie bewertet ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 7,
mit 7 von 10.
Dagegen nimmt sie keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Sie müssen bis jetzt 6-7 Mal aufs Toilette gehen.
Ihr Stuhl ist wässrig, flüssig und halbraunfarbig.
Sie hat auch eine Leichtesfieber,
etwa 38.
Sie hat auch eine sehr starke Nausea und Emesis.
Sie hat bis jetzt 3-4 Mal esangistisches Erbrochen.
Sie hat erbrochen.
Ja, genau.
Sie hat heute ein Stück Schweinehackfleisch gegessen.
Sie hat nach dem Mittagessen angefangen.
Sie hat die vegetative Anamnese,
die Fieber und die Tiere in Sonne.
Sie hat seit 6-7 Jahren in Menapaose gegessen.
Sie riecht seit 40 Jahren ein Pichenzigaretten täglich.
Deswegen hat sie ab und zu Husten.
Aber welche Diabose wurde bei ihr nicht festgestellt.
Sie trinkt abends eine Flasche Bier und trinkt ein Glas Wein.
Sie hat Penicillinallergie, die sich Haut ausschlag.
Sie hat eine exannte Äußert.
Sie hat keine bestimmte Verträglichkeit wie Milchprodukte.
Normalerweise ist sie ganz gesund.
Sie hat Probleme wie Reflex und aufstoßen.
Sie trinkt 2-3 Becher Kaffee.
Sie ernährt sich nicht mit gesundem Essen.
Sie hat keine Zeit, um sich gesund zu ernähren.
Sie hat keine Operationen durchgeführt.
Sie hat Kopfschmerzen und Sefalgie.
Sie nimmt ein 500 mg.
Sie hat ein Brustkrebs.
Sie hat ein Myokartinfarkt erlitten.
Sie ist Taxifahrerin.
Sie ist geschieden und lebt allein.
Sie besprechen für eine Gastroenterizis.
Sie hat eine Diagnose.
Sie hat ein Diagnose.
hat Kardiaprobleme ausschliess.
Genau.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen und
körperlich, ich werde sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Ja, bei der körperlich untersuchen,
ja, körperlich untersuchen,
werde ich
auf jeden Fall palpieren.
Palpation ist sehr wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Ich kontrolliere, ob Sie ein Druckschmerzen
oder Loslassschmerzen
abwärtsspannend hat.
Danach werde ich
auskultieren und inspezieren natürlich.
Bei der Inspektion werde ich kontrollieren,
ob Sie irgendwelche pathologische Veränderungen
hat in Ihrem Bauch.
Zum Beispiel, ichte ruskane sein
oder bei einer Pankretitis
können Zeichen,
Greta, Zeichen wie bläuliche Farbeveränderungen.
Ja, und noch.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch noch?
Diagnostisch, ich werde Blut abnehmen
und danach werde ich einige operativ diagnostische Maßnahmen durchführen.
Was machen Sie im Labor noch?
Erst mal, lassen Sie bestimmt im Labor.
Im Labor werde ich großes Blutspiel,
CRP, BSG, Amine,
Amilas, Lipas, Leber- und Nierenwerte,
ALP,
ALP, Bluribinwerte
und noch.
Was lassen Sie noch im Labor?
Stundprobe, sehr gut.
Bei diesem Fall ist Stundprobe sehr wichtig.
Wir sollten kontrollieren, ob Blutungen
oder Parasiten gibt.
Ja, Leuko können ja beurteilen.
Und danach werde ich Abdominalzoneografie durchführen,
um mögliche Galenblasen, Entzündungen
oder Steinen zu beurteilen.
Dann werde ich
ein Moment
ja, Computerzoneografie im Bauch,
Abdominalzoneografie,
veranlassen aber gegebenenfalls.
Nur wenn es sonst unklar ist, ne?
Genau, wenn Abdominalzoneografie nicht klar ist,
werde ich gegebenenfalls
in der Stundprobe.
Aber was erwarten Sie denn im Ultraschall?
Im Ultraschall werde ich
Galenblasen beurteilen
bei einer Galenblase.
Wenn jetzt Ihre primäre Diagnose richtig ist,
dann können wir vielleicht nicht
Gas genau beurteilen,
wegen vieler Gasen im Bauch.
Genau, und deswegen brauchen wir
vielleicht auch noch eine Aufnahme im Bauch.
Aber zielst du,
und das ist ja wahrscheinlich insbesondere die
Labordiagnostik, ne?
Genau, Labord und Kulinesch.
Genau.
Was ist denn das Entscheidende
bei der Therapie, wenn Sie tatsächlich
die Gastroenterik haben?
Genau, als telepoetisch
werde ich sowohl
eine Flüssigkeit zuvor entnehmen
und als auch
nicht Beschwerde
für die Beschwerdertherapie einführen.
Gegen Beschwerder, ja.
Ein Therapie einführen.
Wie zum Beispiel gegenüber Nausea
und Erbrechen werde ich Antihemätikum verabreichen.
Gegen Fieber werde ich
ein Antipyretikum geben.
Außerdem je nach
die Geiterprobe
werde ich
gegebenenfalls Antipyretikum verabreichen.
Ja.
Und ja, bei diesem Fall
ist viel
Wassertrinken oder Flüssigkeit
geben, sehr wichtig.
Ja, wie heißt das denn,
wenn der Flüssigkeit zu groß ist, wie nennen wir das?
Dehydratation,
Ausdrucknung, nein.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, ja.
Fachbegriff?
Welche Wörter nochmal
für die Ausdrucknung sozusagen,
Ausdrucknung,
Dehydratation, Exikose.
Exikose, ah, genau, genau.
Exikose,
ja, und man kann das immer schön sehen
an der Haut, wobei sie ist ja noch nicht so eine alte Frau,
aber bei alten Leuten ist das so der Klassiker.
Genau, sie haben total recht, genau.
Ich sollte auch hier etwas kontaktieren.
Dann halten Sie mich auf alle Fälle auf dem Laufenden,
was mit der Patientin ist,
und was bei Ihrem Untersuchung rauskommt.
Gut, ja, Sie haben sich wieder wackergeschlagen.
Sehr schön.
Was mir heute aufgefallen ist,
das habe ich letztes Mal, habe ich es auch schon registriert,
aber habe es nicht gesagt.
Sie sagen ziemlich oft, okay, okay.
Ah, okay.
Das heißt bei Ihnen natürlich, ich habe Sie verstanden.
Ja, das kann aber auch ein bisschen missverständlich sein.
Wenn jemand sagt,
ich will schlecht, ich habe solche Schmerzen,
ich sage okay, okay.
Ich finde die Videos vielleicht nicht so gut.
Dann ist es besser zu sagen, ja, ich verstehe Sie,
oder entweder so.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Das ist die eine Geschichte.
Anermesen, denke ich, war komplett und vollkommen,
und da haben Sie nichts offen gelassen.
Sie haben die Patientin mit Namen angesprochen.
Sie haben praktisch die Sachen, die Sie schon erwähnt haben.
Darauf sind Sie eingegangen.
Und haben das nicht nochmal gefragt,
sondern gesagt, ja, Sie haben erwähnt,
dass Sie Rauchrausen haben,
mit viel Zigerrettenrauen.
Sehr schöne Übergänge einfach gemacht.
Das haben Sie super gemacht.
Ich habe eigentlich nur eine winzige Sache.
Und zwar, nachher im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
was Sie nicht erwähnt haben,
sind Ihre Sorgen
und Ihr Stress wegen Ihrer Tochter.
Die Droge, wenn er nicht ist.
Genau.
Das ist sicherlich so ein Punkt,
der für den Reizmagen mitentscheidend ist.
Und jetzt für diese akute Erkrankungen natürlich nicht.
Was man noch überlegen sollte,
gerade bei diesem Fall,
und die gute Frau hat ja nun so ein rohes Fleisch gegessen, ja.
Das schreit natürlich
nach irgendeiner bakteriellen Infektion.
Und muss man ja wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen.
Und das meine ich,
dass es nicht so viel zu viel zu tun ist.
Das meine ich,
wäre gut gewesen,
das ein klein wenig früher zu sagen.
Dass Sie sagen, ja, Sie hat dich vorgestellt,
nach, also mit erheblichen
Magen-Darm-Beschwerden
und starken Schmerzen und extremen Schmerzen
und Übelkeit, also Lausia und
Emesis und Diarrhön.
Und nachdem Sie
einen, zum Mittagessen
ein Brötchen mit
rohem Fleisch gegessen hat.
Ja, also,
da liegt ja irgendwie so ein bisschen auf der Hand,
wo die Ursache für das ganze Elend ist.
Und da gibt es
ein paar interessante Prüfernachfragen,
die haben tatsächlich gefragt, was die häufigsten Ursachen sind,
für Gastroenteritis. Fällt Ihnen dazu was ein?
Sie haben keinen Mikro.
Sie haben kein Mikro an.
Warum? Weiß ich nicht, okay.
Salmonella kann sein? Ja, genau.
Was ist das häufigste?
Häufigste Salmonella.
Die fusst nicht viel, oder?
Nein. Aber welche erinnere ich mich nicht?
Ich habe natürlich auch bei diesem Fleisch Ding
erstmal in Salmonellen gedacht.
Aber das scheint irgendwie
der häufigste Keim hier
in unserem Essen zu sein.
Ah, Yasinien gibt es auch noch, stimmt.
Eine echte Suchaufgabe
für die Leute, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
eine echte Suchaufgabe für die Leute vom Labor.
Dass sie finden, was der Erreger ist.
Gut.
Sie haben sich wieder sehr, sehr gut geschlagen.
Ich würde sagen, Sie müssen vor der Prüferung
überhaupt keine Angst haben.
Ein ganz klein bisschen dieses okay.
Du konkondieren? Ja.
Ich verstehe.
Ich nehme es mal ganz krass.
Ich nehme es mal ganz krass, den Fall.
Mein Mann ist letzte Woche verstorben.
Okay.
Das kommt nicht wirklich gut.
Da muss man natürlich schon sagen,
oh ja, das habe ich jetzt verstanden.
Wenn es irgendwas anderes komplexes ist,
wo sie sagen,
ich habe das jetzt verstanden, was sie mir beschrieben haben.
Dass sie dann vielleicht das nochmal irgendwie,
dass sie das einfach anders sagen.
Ah ja, das habe ich jetzt so verstanden.
Und dann vielleicht nochmal wiederholen.
Gut.
Ein bisschen äh ist auch noch drin.
Aber das werden wir auch nicht so schnell ausschalten.
Das machen alle Deutschen auch.
Die sind grammatikalisch so sicher drauf.
Und sie haben so ein gutes Wortschatz.
Und sie haben so ein gutes Wort und Sprachverständnis.
Das ist schon wirklich sensationell.
Man kann sehr stolz darauf sein,
was sie alles gelernt haben in der kurzen Zeit.
Ich finde es wirklich ganz toll.
Und kann Ihnen nur alles, alles Gute für die Prüfung wünschen.
Vielen Dank.